amantha the the the president does seem
to be in a rush to ease lockdown yeah he
wants schools reopened by autumn even
though dr. Anthony fancy who's leading
his coronavirus task force said in a
separate hearing on Capitol Hill look we
can't rush this we just don't know the
impact yet that this virus has on
children and then that is something we
just can't confirm happening at the
moment they've had quite a public break
in their views on that and what you have
is a further compounding really of this
battle ongoing between politics and
science here in the United States as
particularly Republicans led by Donald
Trump want to push this idea of
reopening now what they're saying at
what was said today by dr. rick bright
who is formally led the government
agency that was leading efforts on a
vaccine it was a pretty stark warning
about what state the US could be in by
the end of the year if there isn't some
kind of master plan put in effect now
americans yearn to get back to work to
open their businesses and to provide for
their families I get that however what
we do must be done carefully with
guidance from the best scientific minds
our window of opportunity is closing if
we fail to improve our response now
based on science
I fear the pandemic will get worse and
be prolonged there will be likely a
resurgence of kovat 19 this fall it'll
be greatly compounded by the challenges
of seasonal influenza without better
planning 2020 could be the darkest
winter in modern history so dr. Rick
bright there who was forced out of his
role by the Trump administration last
month he says because he made early
warnings about the lack of equipment
about the severity of what lay ahead for
America and was criticized for those
warnings at which he says were ignored
he also says that he feels he was pushed
out because he refused to push drugs
treatments untested treatments for
coronavirus like the anti-malarial drug
hydroxychloroquine which the president
was really pushing quite aggressively
for a part long period of time he
refused to do that and he says that
that's one of the reasons he believes
that he was pushed out of his position
now Donald Trump mentioned dr. Rick
bright testimony briefly on his way to
Pennsylvania he's going to a medical
distribution center there and he has
been speaking about what he thinks is
behind dr. Bryce testimony to me nothing
more than a really disgruntled unhappy
person and I'm not just talking about
Alex because Alex said it strongly but
there are a lot of people that do not
like the job he did I don't know I never
met him I don't want to meet him but I
watched him and he looks like an angry
disgruntled employee who frankly
according to some people didn't do a
very good job so Donald Trump pushing
the idea that he has done a very good
job when it comes to handling this
outbreak something that he recognized
from the start the Democrats have a very
different idea that he simply didn't act
quickly enough didn't treat it seriously
enough when the warnings were out there
so what we've really seen on display
this afternoon : is this deep divided
politically coronavirus has become
politicized in the United States you saw
that in the questions that members of
Congress were posing to dr. bright just
in terms of the absolute gulf between
the science and the politics that is
really deepening here in the United
States